bedos plus savary plus brecht plus
arthur buies plus chaillot équation
explosive elle porte sur un thème
toujours d'actualité la dictature
il y appelle baume jean françois chauvey
appel à la résistance cette pièce a
marqué une génération lors de sa
création en france c'était jean vilar en
1960 sur la même scène sous les traits
d'un mafieux new yorkais revue par bedos
revoici la dictature qui pousse sur le
terreau de la passivité de la
collaboration et qui se nourrit de
moeurs du tout numéro boss jouer un rôle
de gangster et les interprétations sont
possibles
moi je ne voulais pas réduire le
personnage à hay clair parce que je veux
parler aux gens d'aujourd'hui je veux
parler aussi de l'époque d'aujourd'hui
jean vilar se réfèrerait explicitement à
berlin et au nazisme
c'était 15 ans seulement après hitler et
moi c'est moi à 0 waaa le dos c'est les
assassinats d'immigrés sarajevo et la
démagogie ce qu'on appelle le talent et
en public notamment d'éloquence le
charisme on dit maintenant
bien passer à la télé etc ce peut être
te fait agréable et c'est aussi
extrêmement pernicieux et extrêmement
dangereux
la force d'arthur oui c'est
l'inoubliable phrase de brecht toujours
actuelle le ventre est encore fécond
d'où a surgi la bête immonde oui le ciel
en colère ont rien vu lire une hausse
inédite et le crime
nocera